[Music]
I'm Pavel and I'm super passionate about
all of these features because I want to
make sure that they're as awesome as
they can be for you guys so before I get
into the presentation scalable
deployments and updates and compute
engine I just want to get a quick read
of the room how many people here are
kind of new to compute in general ok
it's about a quarter and how many people
are using compute but maybe aren't using
manage and infrastructure yet so manage
instance groups ok that's about a third
and then how many people are kind of
like manage it says group experts and
you know them inside it out ok maybe I
can't good good so it's a good mix so
let's talk about setting up
infrastructure serving infrastructure
and whether it's managed or otherwise
there's a little point in setting it up
if you don't get your software deployed
to it and then what you find is as soon
as you get version one out there there's
probably a version two and then there's
a version three four so on in fact some
of our clients deploy software even
multiple times a day but these kinds of
robust deployments of software -
infrastructure that is hot and serving
are only possible if you have the right
tools so that's why today I want to talk
to you about how you can put together a
serving infrastructure with the manage
infrastructure features and get your
software deployed onto it nicely and
smoothly and I built this presentation
both for people who are kind of new to
GC and those who are using GC but aren't
using the manage pieces yet and if
you're a manager instance group expert
then hopefully you'll still get some
value out of some of the new features
that we'll be showing off so let's start
small if you want to build a service
from scratch you might we'll start with
in one server and you just provision a
virtual machine ID you might have given
it some sort of a clever name and then
to deploy you just you know log in and
deploy your software and when there's an
update it's not a problem you just log
in again and update it and then that's
fine but even when then you have maybe
you know two of these servers or three
five or ten you can probably still man
because you can come up with like you
know ten clever names and login to each
one of them and deploy your software in
and that's okay that's getting a little
bit painful but but you can you can
manage but when you start getting into
hundreds thousands or tens of thousands
of servers this manual approach really
doesn't work anymore and that's when you
might have switched to some sort of SEI
CD system where suddenly your servers
are these nameless mindless drones and
they get spun up by by other systems or
by software and now you don't have to
worry about naming them and they just
get created that's really good but when
one of them goes down you have to do
something
someone has to log in and and maybe it
is actually literally you to now restart
this machine recreated you have to take
an action or if traffic dips you
suddenly have all these servers that are
idle and if you had a bad job and it
finished maybe all of the servers are or
Aria are idle and that's why a manage an
instance group is this agent that
monitors your servers for you and takes
action on your behalf to do the right
thing now that's really vague so let's
break it down manage instance group has
four major features one there is the
autoscaler
so that's the thing that people
typically start with four migs and the
autoscaler can create and destroy
machines for you based on load and you
can define what load means for you
whether that's you know CPU utilization
or traffic or with custom metrics
something completely different
there's the auto healer which will
recreate instances that become unhealthy
and go down and again you can define
what unhealthy means for your service
with custom health checks there is now
the one of the new features the updater
which is currently in alpha going to
beta very shortly which will help you
deploy software to your niners instance
group in a controlled manner in exactly
the way you kind of need it and what
works for your service and there is
regional which will split your machines
across different zones to make your
service more available or moving towards
high availability
so that's the the four pieces and the
one thing to keep in mind with the
management sense group is that all of
the pieces are integrated and they work
well together which is great but more
importantly they're also modular which
means that if you don't need auto
scaling you actually don't have to take
it managed instance groups are more than
just groups of scale in scaling machines
if if you have a static work set then
you can have a mega that maybe just uses
auto healing and updates and it doesn't
even use auto scaling or maybe you have
zonal split with with regional and
update but you don't need a lot of
healing it will dig into some of these
features in detail throughout the
presentation so now let's talk about
software or more specifically let's talk
about the software lifecycle and for
purposes of this let's break it down
there's something super simple you write
you build your test and you deploy and
because it's a cycle you do this over
and over and over again so let's say you
build some software and you decided to
package it into a container because
containers are cooled and stackable but
you know one of these containers and you
have your container pack and now you're
thinking I want to get it into the cloud
well it turns out there are a lot of
options for how you actually can deploy
your container into the cloud on one on
the end of the spectrum you can go bare
metal and you can provision your own
machine you can install docker you can
configure it you can install the
container you can configure a networking
and you're basically do all of this
yourself and that works okay on the
other end of the scale you can go with
the container engine and you can ask us
to provision a cluster for you will
manage the cluster for you you then just
upload your containers and that works ok
as well in between the two there is
kubernetes where you basically take care
of your own cluster and you install
communities on it and the kubernetes
does the kind of scheduling of the
containers and now we're introducing
this other option that is essentially UI
pass-through where if all you need is to
put one container on a machine and you
want some automation with that well
we'll take care of some of the details
that you don't have to worry about
setting it up of yourself so let me
explain to you what that means you still
start by
building your container and then
uploading it to the Container repository
is normal and then in the interface when
you go to create a new machine there's a
ticket box which says that I want this
instance to be containerized and then
you just pass a link to the container
open up whatever ports you need come and
give it to command-line and we'll take
care of the rest and what we do in the
background is well provision the Machine
grab the image that has docker already
pre-configured on it it's the Google
official docker image put the container
on it
run the command line set up the
networking the way you open it up and
that's kind of it so for that really
straightforward case where you just
wrapped your software into a container
this could be an option so let's take a
look at what that looks like in practice
with the new interface so you start as
you normally would with creating an
instance and let's give it a clever name
so that we can potentially log into it
later on put it into US Central and
here's the then you pass through where
you can say okay well now I want you to
load this container to go over to the
container repository grab a link to it
and because this is a really simple
front-end let's open up port 80 and now
we have to tell the Container launcher
how to launch the container so it's a
script written in Python so let's launch
by side with fronted and HCP why and
done and that's it and you can see that
it's containerized with that little
summary at the top
the machine is spinning up and as soon
as it gets provisioned what will happen
is in the background as I said will
basically load the container on and run
the command that you you passed us
okay the machine is spun up and ready to
go and when you go into the machine then
you can see that it's containerized at
in the details there's a link to the
container that was pre-loaded on it and
if we go to the actual IP address for
the machine give it a second to refresh
and there you go it's serving the super
simple front-end healthy true and
deployment done okay so that worked
really well for that simple case we
talked about we have one machine and
it's that setup and it loaded the
container with basically just a little
pass through great now if we have a
managed instance group we want to be
able to create multiple conditions
because that one machine might not be
enough right so maybe need two three ten
fifteen of them but before you can
create the group what you need to do is
describe how to create these machines so
the make needs a recipe or a template
which will explain or which will allow
it to provision machines for you right
because the whole point is that now it's
the MiG that'll be creating the
machine's not you manually and when the
template is set up the MiG can be
creating the machine so now let's take a
look at setting up a containerized
managed instance group so same thing we
did with the instances but now we're
going to go with a group of them so
starts we start with creating a template
and of course the interface for creating
a template is very similar to the
interface for creating an instance
because it's basically a description of
how to put together an instance so you
can see the same same checkbox to grab
your container
and we'll grab the same version open up
the port 80 and run the same Python for
a tender script
allow the firewall pass-through for HTTP
and create and of course the difference
is that when we hit create nothing
actually got created in terms of
instances it's just the template that
was created so the descriptor and from
the template now we can say okay I want
you now to create multiple instances so
create a group of these for me and so
this is a second flow into how to create
groups the other main flow is to create
a group from the instance groups tab on
the left side but you can also create
the group directly from a template so
now we'll give our group a name and
we'll call it next containerized
instance Group one leave the single zone
and choose same US central the template
is already selected and now we're gonna
go with ten instances hit create and
we're good to go so now the the group
itself is being created and as soon as
it becomes a resource we can start we
can hook it up to a load balancer
because now that we have ten machines
obviously we want to have a single IP
that can be accessed by the users and so
we don't want to have ten individual
instances so the group is being created
the instances are being created and now
we can tab over to networking and load
balancer and choose one of the load
balancers that was created previously
but it's empty as in there's no back end
so right now that little Balasore has no
target to send traffic to and we can now
from a drop-down select a the new
management instance if we just created
next containerize ig1 hit update and
networking will get connected just make
sure that the instances are all created
so we can check each individual instance
whether it's serving and yes yes it is
if we go direct and go back to our our
load balanced IP
and it takes a second or three to
connect through networking
and there it is and there you go so now
the traffic that went to the load
balancer IP got passed through to one of
the containerized instances and it all
works just like we kind of expected him
great so that worked really nicely for
that setup we have one machine then we
scale up to ten we can connected it to a
load balancer everything's good but now
our service is a little bit exposed to
potentially going to our and there are
typically two things that can bring your
service down so one there is that
concept of a zonal outage right where
all of these instances we put into that
one u.s. central see one I think zone
and if that zone goes down or has an
outage has some networking problems then
your whole service is down and then two
which is quite frankly more likely is
your software might have an issue or the
machine might start crashing and your
service will slowly start experiencing
machine by machine outages and that's
what Auto healing can help with so now
that you're in this manage instance
group you can easily deal with both
cases so let's take a look at the zonal
problem first instead of a regular mega
you can create a regular Regional
Manager instance group the main
difference is that the regional make
will split your instances into zones
proportionally and make sure that there
are always balanced in terms of their
number of instances as you're scaling up
and down so you don't have to worry
about doing that kind of balancing
yourself across the different zones you
just pick a region and we'll make sure
that you have the right amount of
instances per zone so if there's an
outage you're protected but there's a
bit more detail to this so let's imagine
this case you have three zones if you're
if you're ten instances and they're
serving and you're happy and then zone a
goes down well now those three instances
have to be reallocated to the other
zones but if a zone really did go down
you might have a lot of people trying to
do the very same thing which means that
at the time when you need it most you
might be not getting any of instances
because of stock-outs
so that's why the best practice we
advise is to actually over provision or
create additional machines that you
don't strictly need to serve the traffic
you have now but that you can use when
there's an outage and the the best
practice is to provision basically 50
percent more machines per zone now why
50 percent if you have this case and
you've got your three zones and you have
ten machines that are serving and you
have some extras if zone a goes out
those three machines have now somewhere
to fall failover into or have that
traffic be served by other machines
which is great but of course the
machines you over provisioned in zone a
are now offline as well so that's why
you had gotta have to have more in the
other zones so that works really well
for that kind of zonal outages and now
you're more highly available which is
great but for certain use cases that
even that might not be enough and you
might start looking at cross regional
availability which is out of the scope
of this talk but there is a really good
talk that happened yesterday
io2 IO 2o for designing reliable systems
with cloud infrastructure which goes
into great detail of kind of global
availability and how to how to think
about that so so check it out if you
want to know more about how to protect
yourself from outages okay so that was
that was a zonal part but I did mention
that it's more likely actually you know
there might be software machinist issues
so let's look at Auto healing and health
checks now health check is really just a
simple method of determining whether
your machine is healthy that's that's
all it is which typically means you ping
it on some path with a certain frequency
and at some point you determine that a
machine is not healthy or needs to be
you know healed or restarted or
something and both of the balancer and
the auto healer use health checks now
there's an important thing to keep in
mind these services actually have a very
different use for the health check so
while they're both health checks when a
load balancer is using a health check
and one of the machines reports as
offline it'll just stop sending traffic
to that machine so the health check the
way the load balancer thinks about it
it's kind of like a busy signal right
the machine says I can't handle any
traffic anymore I'm not responding the
load balancer says no problem I'll stop
sending you traffic when the machine
comes back online and starts passing its
health checks the load balancer will
resume sending traffic
so that healthcare can be fairly
aggressive and determining machines to
be unhealthy because the cost of going
unhealthy is just hey this one machine
temporarily stops receiving traffic and
then can resume auto healer is different
when a machine goes unhealthy and it's
an auto healing health check the auto
killer will recreate the machine which
is a much more disruptive occurrence so
it does mean that when you're designing
your system you want your auto healer
health checks to be more conservative so
they only trigger if the machine it
truly is down and you want to make sure
that it gets recreated and and basically
healed okay so now let's put it all
together and let's create a regional
management instance group with Auto
healing and load balancing and
containers so we start with the health
checks so let's create two of them the
first one will be for for the auto
healer so we'll call it next simple HD -
aah and for our little app we do the
health check on slash health check just
so it's easy to remember and we'll leave
these parameters as they are basically
so the check interval is three and we
can change the timeout to three and what
that means is that we'll the health
check will be triggered every five
seconds and we'll wait three seconds for
for a response but we're changing as the
threshold to be three as well which
means that it takes three fails for the
instance to become unhealthy right and
and it which I can every five seconds so
it's a fifteen second duration right so
it'll basically check wait five seconds
check wait five seconds check wait five
seconds and and go okay you're unhealthy
for this other health check the low
balancing one the elbe we use the same
path right so the key is that the actual
health check point like the ping the
heartbeat could be the same all we're
playing with is the how aggressive or
conservative conservative it is so this
one is a bit more aggressive so it's
every three seconds and here the the
error is that the timeout is five right
so you can't ping more frequently than
your weight you're waiting for a
response obviously so we're gonna ping
every three seconds and we're going to
I just wait for two responses which
means that it'll take six seconds to
flag an instance as unhealthy for
load-balancing right which is basically
like less than half of our Auto cooling
case and that's what I meant right is
that the load balancer can come more
quickly say hey I'm not gonna send you
any more traffic but the auto healer
will wait a little bit longer before it
clobbers that machine and and recreates
it okay so now we're creating a the
instance group will call it next our mid
containerized one and to make a
containerized all you need to do is
toggle this little switch called making
multi-zone choose.you essential let's
just keep it in the same place but now
you're selecting a region right not a
zone so it'll use the three zones in
that region well select a template
called instance template v1 and let's do
12 machines because I don't know 12
divides into three so we can the four
machines nicely hit create and there you
go and that's all you need it so the
regional machine regional management
since group resources getting created
and then as soon as becomes live we can
start connecting networking to it
all right clicking and the one thing
you'll notice is you have that list of
machines getting creative but now you
can see that they're split across three
zones so you've got the CF and and B in
there now we'll go over to low balancing
just like we did before
and edit the backend to select the newly
created our Meg containerized one
regional managed instance group and
that's kind of all you have to do just
select it as a back end because it's
that's what what it is and the
difference from last time is now we're
going to select that health check that
we created so let's find it
next simple lb for low balancing so we
want to make sure that we grab the the
right health check here hit update and
that's it and then just make sure that
the instance is now got created and the
one thing that we didn't do previously
so let's fix it now we didn't actually
select the auto healer health check so
let's setup out a healing so all you
have to do is in your manage instance
group and you can do this at create or
afterwards you select the health check
and then you can also select an initial
delay so that's basically the amount of
time that the auto healer will wait
before it starts testing an instance
after the instance gets created so it
lets your instance boot up and become
ready before it starts getting
potentially Carla collaborate right so
you don't go into this cycle where it
keeps an auto healing and recreating so
the instances are serving so now let's
go to networking and check that IP
that's been low balanced that's shared
amongst all of the twelve instances for
receiving traffic hit refresh and there
we go and we're serving so we're good
we're up so we have that first part down
right we out of the cycle we did that
cycle once so we wrote some code we
built it into a container we tested it
we deployed it we're serving we're happy
we're good we're ready to go home for
the weekend and then it turns out hey
version two dropped in so now you have
to update this what are your options
well in the past you had basically two
things you could do and both of them
were kind of manuals so one of the
option is to okay let's do all of this
again let's create a Regional Manager
instance group with version 2 and
version 1 is serving and now we'll like
live reconnect the load balancing and
hope for the best and then disconnect
the old instance group and so it's all
kind of your operating on these live
instance groups
switching traffic the other option is
maybe you could change the template
inside your first group and then force a
recreate of all the machines but then
what about your availability right as
you're recreating these machines you're
you're you're not serving traffic so
both of these options were somewhat
workable but a little bit painful so
that's why we introduced the updater
instead of starting with exactly the
details of the updater let's just talk
about what it does so with the highest
level the the concept is really simple
right do you have a version one blue you
want all version one to green and you
just want to update your instance group
without having to touch networking
without having to touch any other other
setups but you still want that control
so let's start simple and let's just do
a simple update from version one to
version two so we start with our
manager's instance group and if we look
at in the details we can see that we're
split in across the three zones four
machines each they're all in version one
so everything's good and now we click
this new new button button called
rolling update and we currently have
version one select - that's our green
build don't touch anything else and hit
update
and there you go the new version starts
getting rolled out now you can see that
actually six machines are being touched
because what's happening is one machine
per zone so three in total are getting
destroyed and three in total are getting
created so we're destroying you know
three old machines and creating three
new machines one per zone and we're
rolling it out and in the details you
can see that now we're saying hey I'm
going to take your template one version
one blue to zero instances and your
version two up to twelve instances
because you're going from you know blue
to green all of them great so that works
nicely for that simple update where you
have to go all version one two all
version two one machine at a time or one
per zone but real life isn't that simple
because what you really want to do is
this if you have a service that is live
and and you want it to be highly
available and you have a new version and
you've probably tested it a lot and
you're pretty confident with it you
still don't want to roll it out 100%
into your life production just plow it
in there and hope for the best
you probably want to do some sort of
canary dip your toes maybe roll out one
machine in one zone see how it performs
make sure that it there's nothing crazy
going on and then go forward from there
so let's do a simple canary update with
the system where we start in the same
place you know all version ones same our
big four zone and let's go to rolling
update and a difference is we have the
twelve blue machines in version one
let's add one and then you release so we
had a version two and we're saying one
instance and you can see that the system
adjusted the count to say well we're
gonna have eleven in the old version and
one in the new version and it had update
and that's it whereas last time you saw
there all six machines were being
updated because we're going through all
of them now it's just we're creating one
and we're destroying one so we're
replacing it and in the details you can
see that we're targeting towards you
know eleven and one so the updater is
going to maintain that that roll out
because that's what you specified okay
so that worked well for the one machine
and let's say you deployed it and tested
it and it works well so now you want to
say maybe let's test performance but in
order to feel good about performance you
want to have a larger rollout so let's
roll out a third or 33% into your your
instance group and you're starting with
that single machine rolled out which is
in in one of the zones and it's it's
serving fine and when you go to rolling
updates all you have to do is say okay
well instead of one instance I'm going
to think about percentages because I
want to have a third whatever the size
of my group I'll put in thirty three for
a third and don't touch anything else
and hit update
and so for that for that rollout what
you can see now is the updater will
create the missing machines so it leaves
that one you already updated and in the
details you can see that the target size
where the what it's going to is a third
in your new version so it's basically
targeting that one third canary rollout
and you can check on its progress and
what the what the target a size is when
it finishes the update you can run your
performance tests and then either roll
forward or roll back okay
so let's stay focused we're doing really
well let's keep going we were skipping
over these parameters and they're
actually that the magic sauce that makes
these updates configurable so everything
we've been doing so far was along the
lines of like I just want to get these
machines out there in a certain
percentage but there's more to this than
you can do the first thing you can do is
instead of rolling out your instances
like we were doing practically where as
soon as you hit update they start
getting created you can be less
disruptive you can say I only want to
roll up my new version when the
instances are getting created for
another reason let's say it your your
instance group is scaling up or scaling
down so that's opportunistic so you can
say I'm only going to update on when the
opportunity presents itself second
parameter is maximum surge now this is
all about the concept of where is the
update happening it's the kind of the
scratchpad so if you imagine you have
your serving set of machines and you
need to take them to a new version
maximum surge allows you to create a
temporary scratch pad on the side where
you can put up new machines without
touching these old ones the ones that
are serving so you put up new machines
and only when they're serving and
confirmed as healthy you take away the
old ones so it's like a temporary
additional space maximum unavailable is
all about this serving space and it's
kind of your disruption budget so what
you can say is I want to update inside
my serving space but I only want to
update like one machine at a time or two
or three or you know 50 percent and so
the two parameters together allow you to
roll your updates out either you know
affecting your existing serving space or
or not and then the final parameter is
maximum wait time which is all about the
rate of the update or how much testing
you want to do so if you want to for
example
just go one machine after the other with
zero wait time which is what we've been
doing so far but you want to say I want
to for example pause for 10 minutes
between each machines because I want to
have a really gradual one machine at a
time so update then you just put in
let's say 10 minutes here and after a
machine updates and passes its health
checks the next one won't start for that
way for that wait time so with all of
these together you can really configure
the update exactly how you want it to be
and so for example like one of the
opposite ways of from safe because
everything we did so far was this idea
of a like a really slow and safe update
what if you have a critical fix or a
fast rollback and you want to update as
quickly as possible
but you still don't want to affect your
serving set then just set your Mac
search to a hundred percent and set your
unavailable to zero and then what the
updater will do will spin up you know
duplicate machines in the new version
make sure they're healthy and then
destroy the old machines only after
these ones pass the health checks
so it'll do an update and basically go
in one step even if it is like dozens or
hundreds of machines and and it's a way
to basically not have to like wait for
the kind of rolling updates so with
these parameters altogether you can you
can get different effects can I switch
to the computer please so for the last
updater it's gonna show the actual
interface just to show that it's it is
working so if we let's say want to plow
through version two as quickly as
possible
and then we changed the instance is two
percent and so that'll be all of the
instances that are going to be surging
so additional no instances unavailable
so I don't want to touch my serving
instances I don't want to wait hit
update
and what you can see is that all of
these new machines in version 2 are
spinning up at the same time but the
version ones are not being touched and
the other important thing is if you tap
over to the details
you actually have 24 machines out of the
12 so we doubled up your capacity which
obviously means that you have to have
the quota for it and you incur the extra
costs but it is temporary it's only for
as long as it takes for these machines
to spin up and pass their health checks
so it might be worth it in certain in
certain cases and in terms of the
training we're going to none of these
and all of these ok can I go back please
ok one more concept with the thinking
what updates that that's kind of
important so when we're talking about
the 1/3 rollout because the managed
instance could have auto scaling you
want that 1/3 to be maintained as you're
scaling up right so that's an important
consideration where an update isn't an
action that's basically you you said it
and you're done an update is a target
because if you want to have a third
rollout then you want that third to be
maintained as you're scaling up and
you're scaling down so in this case if
three instances are getting added two of
them will be in one version and 1/3 will
be in the other version ok that was a
lot of updating so let's let's think
about one more thing we talked about
containers as a packaging thing that's
what we started our little example with
and you know that's what it worked with
and we talked about templates and
changing them and that's all good but if
you're using let's say startup scripts
you don't need to worry about templates
so none of this applies and if you are
using let's say baked images and you
have an image family where you just want
to be recreating your machines and not
touching the template and you pulling
numa images again that's not what you
want so there is also a restore recreate
command where it's the same concept same
parameters in terms of control with MUX
and available minimum wait time but you
can just restart or recreate machines
without touching templates so I started
this whole thing with the idea of
managed and integrated features working
together and now you might be thinking
so ok good so you've got all these
automations and they're all doing their
own thing how do they interact we
touched a little bit on the out of
scaling updating but there's more detail
this what about let's say Auto healer
and updated I talked about the
disruption budget for the updater and
then there's the auto healer so what
happens if you launch an update and
let's say you set your destruction
budget to five because you can only
afford to have five machines down at a
time and you set your MaxEnt available
to five and then the auto healer comes
in and kills three machines
well the updater will know about this so
it will only use two machines while this
is happening because it understands that
three are down four four so for some
other reason when they get healed up and
come back online
the updater will pick them up and now
have its full budget of five to work
with so that works really nicely so you
don't have to mess with the auto healer
if you want to roll out an update and
you can still have your budget but what
about the autoscaler this is a little
bit trickier if you have an auto scaler
and you set it to a certain target
threshold and it figured out that it
needs five machines to serve this
traffic and then you say okay I'm gonna
roll out a new update and I'm gonna take
some machines down so two machines
disappear for update that traffic has to
go somewhere and it'll be served by the
remaining three machines but of course
now they're well over their target load
and so you might ask the question like
will the auto scale there freak out and
start adding these machines well no
because the autoscaler knows that those
two machines are down for updates and
they're coming right back so as soon as
they show up they'll pick up the traffic
and the autoscaler doesn't need to scale
because it knows that it actually wants
five now in the middle of the update and
actually there was more traffic and
suddenly the autoscaler
thought hey I need six machines then it
would spin up additional machines so
it's not like it's paused
it's just including what's happening in
its overall calculations so that's the
idea of it being an integrated system
and of course all of the examples I gave
you where with the UI because it's kind
of more fun to show but it's fully
supported by g-cloud so you can write
scripts and use all these parameters in
g-cloud as well so let's put it all
together we talked about manage and now
you can set up a regional managed
instance group which is resistant to
traffic changes with auto scaling
because you can add and remove machines
based on whatever load you specify or
however you think about load you can be
resilient to
machines crashing with Auto healing you
can take new versions and reload updates
and you can also be resistant to zonal
outages with with regional so now I
wanted to talk to you or share with you
how one of our customers Descartes labs
used all of these features together in
two of their specific use cases now if
you don't know who day card is they are
a machine learning specialist and one of
their big products is crop yield
predictions and famine predictions based
on satellite imagery now like all
machine learning what they do this with
is unsurprisingly a ton of computation
and in fact they run tens and thousands
of cores inside Meg's all day every day
to create these models in practice that
means they actually ended up creating a
managed instance group with a thousand
machines and all of these machines are
pretty beefy to chunk through the
machine learning models but the tricky
thing is when a new version shows up
they don't care about the old version at
all because there's no point running the
old code when when you want to have a
new model so when they're rolling out
their update their disruption budget is
a hundred percent this isn't serving
it's basically a batch job that's just
continuously running on new batches of
data so when you want to roll out a new
version you can do this all at once and
when they run this basically all the
machines get updated essentially in one
step even though it's like a thousand
machines so it's a really fast parallel
update now there are other use case is a
little bit more traditional
once these models get created they
actually have to get served to their
customers and they do this through
custom front ends and these front ends
translate the data in a way that's human
readable and that their customers can
use these now they actually have
seventeen of these front ends each one
is a MIG and it's Auto scaled from 1 to
100 and when a new version comes out all
they need to do is just actually restart
the machines because these startup
scripts for for the for their for their
actual software but because they're
serving they can't take them down fully
so in this case based on in this case
when they're rolling out the new version
all they need to do is restart with a
10% destruction budget right yeah
because
based on their their use case that's not
noticeable by customers but it's also
fast enough to go through all of the
machines and because there's 17 of these
MiG's they can do a scripted rollout
with G Clarke man's going one at a time
but because they're non-blocking all
seventeen gets submitted basically at
the same time and the MiGs update or
restart in parallel now if you want to
actually know more about the card labs
and how they set up their their systems
there is a great talk they did today IO
2 3 5 how the card Labs uses Postgres on
GCP and they also talk about a little
bit more about their setup so it's it's
worth checking out if you're interested
in that use case so there you have it
we started with containers and
deployments of easy container
deployments on single machines or
directly into MiG's we looked at
regional managed instance groups which
now can be split into zones have Auto
healing auto scaling updates and for
updates we looked at the new updater
features which give you a lot of
flexibility and power with how you
version or roll out new versions of your
software to your to your machine to your
MiG's if you want to get started or want
to know more there's plenty of
documentation and I think these slides
will be shared so if you didn't take
great notes no worries and I just want
to leave you with this final thought to
bring it all together even if you want
that kind of direct control of instances
for your infrastructure you don't have
to do everything by hand build the
service by choosing the manage features
that work for you and we'll help you out
with managing your your service you're
not on your own thank you very much I
think we've got some time for questions
as well
[Applause]
[Music]
you